[Applause]
uh little nas x
the king bro man this [ __ ] did
it again this is the
this is the black gay tommy laren yo
lil nicholas this is
outrage culture manipulated to a t and
he is brilliant and tommy larry would uh
would piss off like black women and
black twitter right yep
and lil na's ex knows perfectly how to
piss
off conservative christians and the
important part of that is when you piss
them off it just blows your [ __ ] up
exactly and then you get bigger than
ever yeah and they're a monolith yes
they all think the same way now when i
say they i'm not talking about every
[ __ ] christian
conservative christian but there is a
body of them that think the same way
about things and when they get enraged
they [ __ ] go now there's a few things
with little nazex right now which one
are you
talking about i'm talking about the
sneaker uh but i'm also talking about
the video oh the timing was
he this is a package yeah he knows if
you really want to look at it
his first video went at christian
conservatives
favorite genre yeah that's a good point
an amazing genre of music by the way
an absolutely amazing one a genre of
music i don't know
it might be taking over soon and not by
a gay black
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
maybe we give them a little snippet
later maybe not we'll see but
um so basically he put out this this
music video
i think it's called montero montero i
think that's his first name
yeah montero and uh wild music video we
can get to that in a second but he also
put out uh
a sneaker and he i guess
he linked up with this brand called uh i
imagine
it's supposed to be mischief but msch
right
and they put together the sneaker and
it's like a satan air max
right uh there's one drop of human blood
in it there's all there's a pentagram
there's an upside down cross there's all
these things that would really piss off
mark mark came in here [ __ ] heated
today yeah
yeah my white air max is just
[Laughter]
the rest of the drops are in mark
no there's uh so basically uh i guess
christian twitter went crazy yes um
so much so that nike had to issue a
statement
saying that they were not part of this
collaborative collab was with mischief
and the lo nazix right um but that's
hilarious that like nike had to actually
speak on the issue of course and um
that nike and i guess where how do
christians feel about like
child labor like how do they feel about
that like
is that devilish a little bit to like
make child slaves
biblical yeah was it i don't think kids
had jobs back in the day
they were getting pregnant at like 12
back in the day whatever bruh you old
enough
thirteen dude okay you're right the jews
established the age
12 they look at you like a weirdo but 13
you were an adult
right dove you're a man that's it yeah
13.
there's a lot of middle eastern slavery
in the bible and uh so i guess they're
okay i can't imagine that they were like
you know what 18 is
the cutoff for slavery in the bible you
know i mean i bet you there were some
child slaves in the box yeah
probably huh honda just to get into the
crevasses
little
[Laughter]
anywho uh they're absolutely pissed off
about this [ __ ] and i think it's like uh
i think it really speaks more to the
fact that there's nothing going on
like when christians start getting upset
about devil [ __ ] you know life is good
yeah it's the 90s again maybe we're in
the 90s or was it the 80s when was it
90s
satanic panic because this guy is
probably
probably 90s but it always happens when
like everything's boring yeah when
everything's boring and there's no
like oh worried about the wall or
worried about a race war in america
we're worried about there's
literally nothing pissing people off on
social media
then christians go the devil's bet yeah
yeah yeah right
then marilyn manson who ended up being
kind of dead
yeah yeah whenever christians are right
about some [ __ ]
i think they need to come out later on
because they told you yeah they don't i
told you so enough
you know what i told you so now because
they're waiting for their big i told you
so when jesus comes back yeah
so they just keeping it all in the
pocket because right now they say i told
you so they'd be like really dumb
we're jesus that's great and if you
didn't believe them about that one they
got to run through the list of other
[ __ ] they were right about before you
got to heaven
oh yeah you got to admit you were wrong
about every single thing that they said
was going to happen
they're going to force us to get
vaccines we're like shut up that means
now you can't even go back to new york
unless you get vaccinated
[Laughter]
so how do we feel what are we thinking
what is uh what is little nazak is he a
genius does he figure out outrage
culture this is the genius
the genius is he took a song that it's
fine
yeah like old town world or whatever
that's just slack
this is fine yeah but it don't matter
it's going to do crazy numbers because
of the outrage behind 32 million already
that's just something [ __ ]
joyner lucas was at him like hey man
what the [ __ ] my kids are seeing this he
said three
wait he said that he tweeted he was like
yo man you didn't put a [ __ ]
disclaimer up or nothing no
son jordan lucas your kids are gay bro
you got some gay ass kids just watching
gay porn on youtube all day
little knowledge that's your kids he
responded with something like old town
road is about adultery
and it's like doing drugs or some [ __ ]
like that you don't have a problem with
that
was he doing the adultery and the drugs
in the video because that's the thing
another dude's abdomen and he was
grinding on the devil
the licking of the neck was when i was
like yo i thought it was his abdomen
he no he would be licking he did both
technically i think he played all the
characters so he's kind of just
jerking off yeah that's fine oh he
played he played
all the characters how was he dancing on
himself i mean body double for
some some of the parts like the stomach
and [ __ ] like that but if you look at
the face it's him
on a little racist fan yeah those were
different black guys
yeah guys were different black guys
that's an [ __ ]
bro it wasn't was it really the same
yeah it's him
well all of a sudden y'all look
different huh which is progress
there we go point is i guess it's less
gay if you're just doing it to yourself
on body doubles but is it
i don't know bro can't we just be a
little taken aback because this is
we haven't seen this before yeah we
heard songs with drug use and adultery
this is the first time i've seen a dude
twerking on satan
in a video yeah so it's just new it's
just
new i don't even care about the satan
thing like if yeah yeah i don't care
like the same thing didn't bother me at
all because i don't really believe in it
yeah you know like
i believe in heaven because it might be
there but
i'm not gonna believe in satan i'm not
gonna believe in hell what's the point
of that like
yeah i'm not right like you're just
gonna believe the good stuff yeah
like if i don't believe in it all i
might as well just pick the good [ __ ]
and be like maybe i'll go there that's a
valid point yeah because
you're a christian yeah that's why i'm
so pissed off by this [ __ ] dude
yeah because if you don't
help me if you don't believe in hell and
then you go there then you can believe
it when you're there you know what i
mean you're like i'm all right i'm here
i'm gonna call it heaven you're not
gonna tell me what it is
uh-huh perception's reality exactly yeah
suck it satan
suck it he believed you yeah yeah
anselmo
yo honestly why are christians agreeing
with this video
because he's saying the devil's gay
and they're like gay people go to hell
and he sent himself to hell
this is the most christian song when you
think about it christian
is a christian ass song what the hell
are you upset about dudes working on
dudes where should that be
according to y'all oh there you go hello
video belongs in church as far as i'm
concerned
al i'm not christian yes you are
yes you are how do you feel about this
mark bro i would say
he did it right then like
according to the book well actually i
think that's what he said the
the video was about he was like this is
me making a response to all the people
that told me to go to hell for being gay
he's like like conservative twitter says
that i'm going to hell they tell me to
go to hell so fine i'll show you what
hell's like can i just ask a question
about that
like do you need to tell him to go to
hell like is that already
gonna happen yeah right like why you
don't need the thought of somebody yeah
why are you doing god's job for you yeah
yeah i guess you don't understand that's
blasphemy you ain't god's secretary
that's a good point
sending messages back and forth from god
who the [ __ ] are you
let's do your regular job god over here
like i got it
i'm god yeah i'm sending his ass here i
wrote a whole book